hey guys what's up this is andrew with
trainsenses.com
so today i want to make a big focus guys
on marine and attere so first i know
what you guys are going to tell me and i
have already posted a recap about amc
ngme on my discord as every day so if
you want to know my view about those two
legendary stocks just go check it out
but in this video i want to show you
guys some very interesting stuff on
marine and ater so let's get into it
[Music]
alright so let's start with marine first
so we have here a very strong move up
around 60 70 that happened yesterday it
happened on the news that marine renewed
a revenue share agreement with google so
this has been actually spotted guys in
our radars uh as soon as the 1st of
september as you can see guys on our
discord uh where we share with you a lot
of alerts about options about stocks we
manage our own portfolio as well we
started it september so of course we
started with a tough market but things
are doing very well there and here you
can see that we posted an option play
about marine on the 1st of september all
right so this was the play it was a cold
spread because we knew this could take
some time so whatever you're not sure
the move up is going to happen right
away you don't just buy calls because
they are bleeding very fast okay you're
going to pay a lot of theta so you do
something to reduce your premium here we
decided to buy 7.5 calls and sell 12.5
on october maturity once again this has
been posted guys on the 1st of september
when marine was trading around
6.
so what happened later we got here this
move down so basically the alert was
given to us because we broke the support
whenever you have you know a move down
like this that is consolidating and then
suddenly you have a breakout above
whenever it's re-testing this level
around six 650 it is time to get in you
don't buy at eight you wait for a
pullback at least this is the method
that i shared there with you and then
why do you think guys we have this
strong move up here i mean now what i
want to show you guys here is that
why did we have sorry the signal before
the strong move up at this level a few
weeks before and i can tell you you know
you can see look the volume is much
bigger and i would need to check if
there was some news that day but i'm
pretty sure that it's the same news it's
just you know people some people know
before others and they got in here and
then other people got in here so what is
the situation for now if you are long
this cold spread a cold spread is not to
be in wound you need to wait because the
time value is going with you guys
so the call spread is here bam bam bam
okay so this is your payoff now so you
are here around 10 so you have no no
time value the term value is even
slightly positive so you're just going
to convert slowly to your pnlm maturity
so whenever you buy a code spread it's
not to be unwound you need to wait until
maturity so here the right thing to do
is to wait now what are the price target
for marine to have an idea about that i
checked the synthetic shock interest
which is one of the reason we posted
this alert and when you go and check
what is happening here you can see that
there is six percent so basically here
i'm retrieving all the information about
the option market and i uh um
and i transformed this into synthetic
short exposure and you can see that we
have right now six point four percent of
synthetic short and it can grow up to 10
percent the regular shot is 10 and what
is interesting is to know where it's
coming from so you can see that it's
mostly coming you need to look for the
green cells it's mostly coming from here
from the 7.5 oh surprise just where we
were so everything is coming from here
so that's why i'm not so positive about
marine i would take profits so the call
spread is not to be won but if you have
shares or just calls i think that all
the area between 10 and 20 is good to
take profits there are a lot of back
holders guys in the stock as you can see
the stock was trading much higher a long
time ago and we had here a massive move
up as well before and we didn't make new
highs so
i'm not so positive for the medium term
but for the short term we might see some
more momentum coming on the upside
especially because we have this gamma
here but we don't have that much gamma
higher as you guys can see the highest
strike we have is the 20 strike and it's
not that big compared to what we have on
the 7.5 here is the number of options so
100 000 and here we go up to 500
thousands so the gamma was around 7.5 so
this is where we had the move i don't
think the option market would help us to
move strongly higher once again i have
targets between 9 and 20 here but i
would personally take profits much
lower than 20 around 12 to me it's good
to good to go and just keep let it run
maybe a little bit to 20. so second one
let's check uh utter same guys so here
this one is a pain in the ass first
because we have spotted this trade let
me show you guys so 9th of september so
this is the option alerts that we share
with you guys so attai was posted the
10th of september as you guys can see
cap and handle plus breakout that was
the situation it was trading at 10 so
before the first move up and once again
here we advised to do a cold spread uh
and we tried to get in but unfortunately
we missed it in our live training
portfolio so we didn't get in there
which is a bit frustrating we were
placed at uh around 10 you know that day
and it looks like uh i don't know maybe
you guys are just front running us like
the beads were higher than ours i don't
know if it keeps going like this we're
gonna stop posting alerts i can tell you
now but to be honest um i'm very happy
that some of you uh jumped in we were
placed a bit lower that's the game we
didn't get filled we had then a second
opportunity so once again the reason was
here the breakouts that we had here so
that's why we posted the alerts and then
look we posted the alert again guys when
we had the pullback
so here again we post the alert breaker
terrary tested on the 19th of september
once again we advise to take a cold
spread but you can take shares here it
would make sense as there was an easy
stop loss to use around nine or eight
just below the moving averages we had
many plays that day so we didn't get in
again which is a pain but it's still
looking very good i think we are set up
to make a nice fifth wave so here my
view is more bullish the reason being
that look at that guys so at their bam
okay
so as you can see guys the synthetic
shot is 18 and the maximum synthetic
shot can go up to 27
which is 10 more and we have 20 percent
of natural uh short interest and what is
very interesting so first thing we have
twice
more
short interest than we have on marina
then we look at where this is coming
from so we are trading around 15 so the
money is here but look the 35 strike
guys it's very big and we have as well
on the 20 25 so here the option market
is much more animated and this is going
to create some upside gamma okay because
whenever the market makers are short
they are short gamma and when the stock
is moving higher they are forced to buy
shares every day so to me this setup is
looking better
do we have some back holders we don't
have those back holders that got in a
long time ago maybe we have a few here
but they are
no they are not in the money yet so
maybe we have some bag holders here but
still uh the move is very clean so i
think we're gonna develop doing a one
two three four five just like i posted
guys uh on this code and the target is
40 guys why 40 because i use fib
projections once again guys where this
is coming from i'm just showing you guys
that i'm not inventing anything i'm just
using some theory that is working very
well page 79 guys in the bible and here
you can see let me zoom a little bit
fifth waves they are usually equal to
1.618
of one plus three or 0.618 okay so this
is this relation that we are having here
guys either 1.618 in this situation or
0.618 times one plus three so this is
the method we are applying here guys and
you can see that the 1.618 is around 35
which makes sense because we have for me
some resistance at 39 some resistance at
26 so i think that we're gonna break 26
i think that we're gonna make some quick
highs around 35 29 so once again
unfortunately we missed this one but
don't worry we're gonna get the next
ones if i were in this trade uh i would
start to take profits around something
thirty percent at twenty three percent
at twenty six thirty percent at thirty
nine and what we're gonna do guys we're
gonna take a bearish trade here whenever
we reach 39 because i can tell you that
this is not gonna go much higher than
this the reason being that there is no
more gamma okay no more gamma no more
momentum so no more buyers and people
are gonna take profits and we are gonna
buy puts whenever we go there and we're
gonna of course post an alert so that's
it for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i see you guys